turning down a job opportunity
accidentally auditioning for a porno
marrying her ex while she's still with
leonard believe it or not these weren't
the worst choices penny made on the big
bang theory stick around because we're
about to reveal her most regrettable
decision kaylee cuoco's penny goes
through quite a lot during her long run
on the big bang theory during the show's
tenure she makes several major moves to
change the direction of her often
chaotic life she switches ambitions and
goals manages to endure the non-stop
shifts in her relationship with leonard
gains real friends in the form of
leonard's friends and even manages to
make a reliable friend group of her own
with her eventual besties amy and
bernadette all that said thanks to a
tendency to be impulsive with her
decision making not all the choices
penny makes in her life are smart or
good for her i get it i screwed up this
is all we're gonna talk about the rest
of the day why are you mad at me you're
the one that did this stupid thing i'm
just trying to fix it before the show
begins she marries her ex-boyfriend zach
in las vegas and never realizes the joke
ceremony was real forcing her to seek an
annulment from her ex so she can marry
leonard in season 7. after all that she
still agrees to elope to las vegas with
leonard in season 9 a completely
impulsive gesture that cuts their family
and friends out of the equation and
forces them to orchestrate a bigger
private ceremony later on also
incredibly after insisting she doesn't
want to have kids for the entirety of
the show's run in season 12 she ends up
pregnant by leonard thanks to a birth
control mishap in short penny's made a
lot of questionable decisions and has
dealt with the fallout but one decision
stands above the rest as arguably the
worst one she ever makes on the big bang
theory yes in spite of every other tough
choice in her life penny's decision to
give up her dreams of being a successful
actress is still the hardest one for
fans to take her life as a working
actress is what drives the character
from season 1 to season 8. it's why she
moves to california from nebraska in the
first place and ends up living next door
to leonard and sheldon while her acting
career definitely has its ups and downs
including an embarrassing incident in
which she shows up for a cat food
commercial and finds out it's an
audition for a pornographic film she
seems to weather these bumps with grace
in the hope of making her dreams come
true for much of the show this means
that she has to live a few inches above
the poverty line while bartending and
waiting tables at the gang's local
cheesecake factory
guys guys you're never gonna believe
this what happened i just got a part on
a tv show but after quitting the
cheesecake factory to focus on her
acting career in season sevens the
hesitation ramification penny
experiences extreme embarrassment when
her role in an ncis episode is cut after
she tells her family and friends to tune
in and watch her her confidence in her
acting dreams is shaken and though
there's hope she might land a role in
the new star wars film thanks to
leonard's support she switches vocations
and becomes a sales representative for
bernadette's pharmaceutical company in
season 8. the big bang theory generally
portrays this as a positive career move
for penny who climbs the corporate
ladder and is such a good rep that she's
nearly scooped up by bernadette's
competitor but it's not a job she shows
any particular passion for even though
her apparent natural skill in the role
definitely gives her a confidence boost
that said she ultimately has no real
emotional attachment to the job and
nearly leaves it when zack offers her
another career opportunity in season 10
which she doesn't take because the idea
upsets her new husband leonard as tough
as her acting career is to maintain
penny shows both a passion for acting
and an aptitude for it throughout the
big bang theory she may make more money
in pharmaceuticals but there's never a
sense of joy and triumph like the kind
she experiences when her performance in
a play draws an emotional response from
her friends in season 6's the monster
isolation while penny seems pretty happy
with her life by the time the big bang
theory wraps up its run fans still
consider her career shift as step
backwards for the character it
definitely takes some excitement out of
her storyline making the career swap the
worst choice she made on the show check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]